[Musique]
ça faisait très longtemps que marie
attendait pour apporter sa robe
enfin elle peut se marier avec françois
son amoureux des 20 dernières années ça
fait depuis deux ans que je travaille
fort là dessus si moi je la voir de quoi
produire aux invités qui est important
dans nos coeurs qui étaient bienvenus
tout est prêt tout est l'os tout fait à
la main le couple avait prévu se marie
en 2020 puis en 2021 et finalement en
2022 on avait notre date initiale dessus
qui était le 25 juillet 2020 on a décidé
laisser ça comme ça
[Applaudissements]
et l'événement est encore plus
significatif qu'il ya deux ans l'année
qu'on était disposé à marie françoise et
l arrêt qui avait un cancer
chaque été opéré
il est très pâle chimio
il ya eu une autre opération le 10 mai
par contre avant de passer à travers ça
c'est mes parents m'ont paru au fil du
temps des proches sont décédés d'autres
se sont éloignés sans oublier la co vide
qui fait toujours des siennes si bien
que les invités sont passés de 126 à 90
ce qui n'a pas empêché le budget lui de
bondir de 50% à 30 mille dollars ici
j'étais chargé une cette augmentation
minime à comparer c'est vraiment à cette
table la musique s'y met j'ai dit lui
aussi parce qu'il voulait monter la
croix fry séparer ses juges ça monte
comme 250 classes de plus c'est bon
c'est normal mais en fait j'aime
beaucoup les robes la saison est hyper
occupy pour toute l'industrie du mariage
selon cette planificatrice et ça roule
un petit peu car et ça roule bien mais
effectivement il ya beaucoup de pénurie
de main d'oeuvre dans plusieurs salles
non seulement au niveau des salles mais
des traiteurs fleuristes la plupart des
fournisseurs ou honorer les contrats
remportés avec des hausses de prix
limités sauf la possibilité aux gens de
changer d'idée ou de prendre quelque
chose de moins dispendieux les mariages
planifier plus récemment eu subi plus
fortement l'inflation c'est sûr et
certain qu'un bon 20 à 25% de plus cher
dans les factures way par rapport à l'an
dernier ouais elle s'attend à une autre
augmentation d'au moins 25% pour les
mariages de l'an prochain probablement
que les gens vont décider de réduire
aussi parce que c'est sûr que la seule
façon de réduire un budget de mariage
c'est de réduire le nombre d'invités
donc les gens qui me disent qu'ils
veulent inviter 200 personnes qui ont un
budget de 20 mille dollars c'est sûr que
c'est difficile à faire très très occupé
le centre de congrès de saint-hyacinthe
accueille une vingtaine de mariages
cette année soit le double de la normale
on maintient toutes les tarifications
qui ont été pris par la suite pour ce
qui est des amis prochaine sauf qu'on a
des augmentations à prévoir le titre
facilement 15 à 20 % d'augmentation
il y a déjà une demi-douzaine de
réservation pour l'an prochain et
plusieurs demandes pour 2024 c'est sûr
qu'ils sont toujours mieux de se prendre
plus tôt que tard parce que
définitivement si ses peurs la
tarification qui va changer s'il est la
disponiblité talk on aurait plus
nous on bloque les prix à peu près six
mois avant le mariage à ce moment là on
garantit le prix qu'on donnera mais là
on n'a aucune idée de ce qui va se
passer on est complet pour 2022 qui ont
fini 2023
marie et françois on arrête et planifie
il réalise enfin le rêve on voit son
festif puis plein d'amour au 2 mai plein
d'amour aussi avec nos amis nos enfants
nos petits-enfants nous mon frère et sa
chaussure c'est important pour eux
et les mariés peuvent dire mission
accomplie
ici marie claude morin radio canada à
saint jude